[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le président poutine a choisi la guerre
cette guerre n'est pas un conflit entre
l'otan et l'occident d'une part et la
russie d'autre part kiev en alerte quasi
permanente
l'hypothèse d'une attaque terrestre
russe plane plus que jamais sur la
capitale il n'y a pas de troupes ni de
base de l'otan en ukraine ce sont des
mensonges la russie n'est pas agressé
elle est l'agresseur des ukrainiens du
côté de ça pour y tient on est dans le
sud est de l'ukraine des ukrainiens qui
résiste à une invasion russe des reçus
contrôle le territoire qui entoure une
centrale nucléaire ils ont ordre
d'effacer notre histoire d'effacer notre
pays de nous effacer tous les troupes
russes et leurs blindés sont toujours en
attente au nord de la capitale d'après
ce rapport du secrétariat américain à la
défense publié hier soir ils font face à
une résistance plus importante que prévu
ils ont aussi des problèmes
d'approvisionnement bonjour vous êtes en
panne moi je vous remet jusqu'en russie
a beaucoup savent où vous allez vous
êtes sur la route de kiev là
à bon il faut pouvoir tenir tous les
bouts pouvoir exercer les pressions les
plus fortes sur poutine sur les
dirigeants russes sur les oligarques les
les condamnés économiquement geler leurs
avoirs rt france est en direct pour
encore quelques minutes quelques heures
c'est officiel la chaîne d'information
russe cessera d'émettre aujourd'hui
décisions prises par l'union européenne
voulait réquisitionner les villas des
oligarques russes au profit des réfugiés
et craignant
bien au moins ces villages serviront à
quelque chose le fait qu'un dictateur
russe est envahi un pays étranger un
coup pour toute la planète
je prends des mesures fortes pour
m'assurer que nos sanctions fasse mal à
l'économie russe l'assemblée générale
des nations unies a condamné par un vote
écrasant cette agression
la communauté internationale a ainsi
montré son unité
les équipes sportives de russie ont été
exclus des grandes compétitions
internationales
un certain nombre de candidats qui sont
décrédibilisés décrédibilisé par leur
proximité pas la mairie de la ligne à
mais aujourd'hui mélenchon qui ont dit
qu'ils voulaient des poutines français
notre croissance aujourd'hui au plus
haut sera immanquablement affecté
le renchérissement du prix du pétrole du
gaz des matières premières a et aura des
conséquences sur notre pouvoir d'achat
demain le prix du plein d'essence
le montant de la facture de chauffage le
coût de certains produits risque de
s'alourdir encore et maintenant eu une
certaine instrumentalisation du drame
ukrainien pour que les français se
détournent les yeux du bilan d' emmanuel
macron des propositions des candidats il
va falloir encore une fois aussi que
peut-être après
la semaine prochaine qu'il endosse aussi
son dossard de candidats est qu'il
revienne sur la décision qu'il avait
prise de ne pas participer à des débats
avec les autres candidats elle avoir une
campagne gagne l'élection présidentielle
il y aura une campagne il y aura un
débat démocratique il est important
c'est puissant de quoi peut être
monsieur poutine il a quand même pas la
possibilité de régler
le rythme des élections afin surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'action il est
évident que nous ne réussirons pas à
réunir les 500 parrainages
exigé pour concourir à l'élection
présidentielle il y en a quand même qui
semble ne pas les avoir ces époux tous
et philippe poutou philippe poutou qui
était quand même candidat qui avait
réussi là d'un foie qui en est loin
françois asselineau pareil et cristiano
et christiane taubira qui aura fait un
petit tour et puis s'en va et le décès
de jean pierre pernaut jean pierre
pernaut journaliste présentateur
emblématique de la chaîne jean pierre
pernaut qui avait 71 ans